>> I HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH MY
BROTHER.
I ALWAYS HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH MY BROTHER.
BECAUSE HE IS MY BROTHER AND HE
IS MY BEST FRIEND.
AND OBVIOUSLY HE WAS AWARE OF
WHAT WAS GOING ON.
HE WAS NOT COVERING THE STORY.
HE HAD RECUSED HIMSELF.
>> Harris: THAT’S NEW YORK
GOVERNOR ANDREW CUOMO NOW
DEFENDING HIS BROTHER FOR
ADVISING HIM ON HIS VARIOUS
SCANDALS INCLUDING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS.
HE ALSO SAID QUOTE, UNQUOTE, I
TALK TO JOURNALISTS ABOUT
SITUATIONS ALL THE TIME AND
THEY TELL ME THEIR ADVICE.
JOE CONCHA TORCHED CHRIS CUOMO.
>> HE IS FIERCELY LOYAL TO HIS
FAMILY, OKAY.
GO WORK FOR YOUR BROTHER THEN.
YOU ALREADY DO ALREADY.
MIGHT AS WELL GET PAID FOR THAT
ASPECT.
THAT’S WHAT’S UNBELIEVABLE
ABOUT THIS OR RUN FOR OFFICE
YOURSELF.
HE IS GETTING CRITICIZED BY THE
LEFT.
NOT A RIGHT OR LEFT WING
ARGUMENT.
IT IS A PRAGMATIC ARGUMENT.
>> Harris: TAMMY BRUCE IS HERE
AND RICHARD FOWLER IS HERE
RADIO TALK SHOW HOST BOTH FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTORS.
TAMMY, WHEN I HEAR THE GOVERNOR
SAYING HE GETS ADVICE AND TALKS
TO WITH OTHER JOURNALISTS, NOW
I’M CURIOUS ABOUT WHY CNN ISN’T
INVESTIGATING AND PUBLICLY
SAYING THAT.
WERE THESE OTHER JOURNALISTS AT
CNN?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK HARRIS
THIS IS NOT UNUSUAL.
WE HAVE NOW GROWN USED TO THIS.
IT CAN’T JUST BE THAT NETWORK.
WE KNOW IT’S THE BROADCAST
NETWORKS, MSNBC HAS AN ISSUE
AND NEWSPAPERS HAVE ISSUES AND
A DISTRUST OF LEGACY MEDIA.
WE SEE THIS RESOLVING DOOR AS
WELL WHETHER IT’S JAKE TAPPER,
WHO WAS A DEMOCRAT OPERATIVE ON
CAPITOL HILL.
MANY PEOPLE DON’T KNOW THAT.
OF COURSE, GEORGE
STEPHANOPOLOUS AND IT BECOMES
DIFFICULT BECAUSE YOU SEE THAT
THEY DON’T COVER THE NEWS
REALLY.
IT REALLY IS AN OPINION NETWORK.
THEY SHOULD JUST ADMIT THAT
THEY ARE AN OPINION NETWORK AND
THEN, OF COURSE, CHRIS CUOMO
HAS OTHER ISSUES WHEN HE HAD
COVID, YOU KNOW, TELLING PEOPLE
THAT HE IS BURIED IN HIS
BASEMENT AND ISOLATED AND THEN
WE FIND OUT THAT WAS UNTRUE AS
WELL.
SO AMERICANS ARE MAKING THEIR
CHOICE.
THEY ARE NOT CHOOSING THAT
PARTICULAR NETWORK.
I THINK THAT’S THE MESSAGE THAT
AMERICANS CAN SEND ABOUT WHAT
INFORMATION THEY CONSUME, WHO
THEY SUPPORT.
EVEN LIBERALS HAVE STOPPED
WATCHING THAT NETWORK AND AS
FAR AS THE GOVERNOR, THE SMUG,
HORRIBLE ATTITUDE THAT
CONTINUES THAT NOTHING MATTERS
EXCEPT WHAT AFFECTS HIM AND
WHAT HE THINKS, THE CHOICES HE
MAKES UNDER MULTIPLE FEDERAL
AND STATE INVESTIGATIONS
BECAUSE OF HIS ATTITUDE HE
FEELS SO IMPEEROUS THAT NONE OF
IT MATTERS.
OF COURSE HE WILL HAVE THAT
ATTITUDE AND FED IN PART BY